well there are certain things that give
me really some girls have and don't have
and then i think beauty is a hard thing
man that's the one thing i kind of
appreciate about the woke movement with
like fat acceptance take it easy take it
hey hold easy no he's not i'm not a
friend of the woke movement in a lot of
ways because i think it's a lie but
but i do think that like when you put
pressure
when it's acceptable to make fun of
somebody for being
not as pretty conventionally pretty it
[ __ ] their life up agree yeah they
should not be made fun of yeah now
should they have contracts at victoria's
secret
here's what i think about that
here's what i think
if the marketplace will buy your product
because you are advertising to a certain
segment of the population that is
overweight and if that's a good business
decision you guys go ahead if si thinks
that's a good idea go ahead
so how many how many magazines are you
selling i just want to know i bet not
many
i bet you they sold more when they had
the diamond like like [ __ ] uh tyra
banks on there in their primary
or as you know we're talking about it
and we've been talking about it for a
while and it created that that means
sells magazines but also you look at
abercrombie who got you know
destroyed but when they started they
didn't even offer bigger sizes no and
they were the number one company in
america and then now they're more woke
which they should be because what they
were doing was
horrible yep kind of funny but also
horrible and now that they're more woke
you know they're not nowhere near what
their sales used to be uh i agree
i agree because let's be honest they're
selling a dream that's not possible well
the the the debate and i think it's not
even the debate is
there is a standard of beauty that seems
to transcend culture and time in a lot
of ways like you know when you see an
impossibly beautiful woman okay
like john conley when she was young
uh who who are you talking about the
woman you saw in person margot robbie or
any
but there are some women like that will
knock your [ __ ] dick into the dirt
you see them and you just go
what the [ __ ] is going on i think it was
the one girl who was in pearl harbor who
do you see in person she's from oh uh
kate beckinsale when you see someone
like that bro i thought it was an angel
i know that i was at an oscar party i
thought it was an angel strolling
through the party i was like
drunk cindy crawford when she was
younger okay
saw her in new york you can forget it
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] where you're
from everyone recognizes they go i don't
africa i don't care where you're at you
go holy [ __ ] there there was this
ethiopian woman when i was in saudi
arabia i was a young i was the first
time i realized what true beauty was
this ethiopian woman in saudi arabia she
comes in
and she was friends with a woman who was
working there and she was even as young
i looked at my mother i go mama she's
mommy what's going on here like i
couldn't my mother said i was mommy i
was [ __ ]
how old were you 11 or 12. my mother
said you didn't take your eyes off her
mommy no one could yeah she's just i
call my mom i still call her still call
her mommy i know it drives me nuts i
call my mom i don't i say big mike to my
dad because i can't call him daddy it's
just way too embarrassing yeah daddy's
but i never called my mom or dad i
called him mommy and daddy so all my
girlfriends would laugh so hard i'd be
in college going mommy can you tell me
no i laughed too because when i when i
would come to your sister's house when
she had those barbecues yeah she'd like
pride did you talk to mommy or daddy
yeah no she'd go mommy said i'm like hey
you guys are 50. quit saying that man